a massive explosion lights up the night
sky over the pavlograd region in eastern
Ukraine
smoke Trails suggest possibly exploding
Ukrainian weapons but not so say
officials who rarely admit to Russian
missiles hitting military targets
they say this was an industrial
Enterprise and there's at least 19
apartment buildings 25 private homes and
six schools were damaged or destroyed by
the attack
was at home with his wife when the early
hours of Monday morning There Was An
Almighty blast
ERS
once I heard the first explosions I
shouted to my wife let's quickly put on
clothes and get out we'd only got to the
corridor when I heard another explosion
I was thrown by the Shockwave windows
were blown out it's good we weren't
Outdoors because I don't know what would
happen
we were in the corridor putting on shoes
when both doors were smashed out by the
explosion wave then there was fire I ran
outside and saw the garage was destroyed
foreign
Ukrainian officials say Russia launched
18 missiles at the cube and dinipro
petrovsk regions 15 of which were
successfully intercepted by air defense
Victoria Supreme's daughter lies in bed
lucky to have escaped injury or worse
officials say dozens of people were
injured in the attacks including
children
we rushed to the hallway and laid on the
floor and then the explosion wave
Twisted the door had we stayed for five
more seconds we would have been trapped
here then there were more explosions my
child will need psychological help it's
horrible
these attacks come just three days after
25 people including six children were
killed by a Russian missile hitting an
apartment building in the city of uman
central Ukraine
Russia repeatedly says it doesn't
deliberately Target civilians
thousands have been killed by missiles
drones and shelling of densely populated
towns and cities since its invasion of
Ukraine in February last year
Russian missiles and so-called Kamikaze
drone strikes targeting areas deep
inside Ukraine have increased in recent
days now it's impossible to confirm as
to whether these are in fact an attempt
to buy Russia to hit Ukraine's supply
lines ahead of an expected Ukrainian
counter-offensive but the UK defense
Ministry says Russia has for months been
preparing what it describes as some of
the most extensive defensive lines seen
anywhere in the world in decades chance
traffic Al Jazeera Cube